yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Marit - sorry my right - okay
I'm going to
oops he is giving me please
hooray the sad news is I mean this is
this line is just bad forward but I
haven't looked it looked at it yet
so I only know that it is terrible but I
don't really know why terrible is strong
where this it's just in current yeah
it's an incorrect way of playing so um
Bishop c5 I've had the much better
development here
okay
what are you doing here Marit
where is he canceling for example okay
the question is I'm like and simply I
should probably at one point retreat the
King from e6 I'm doing this now let's go
all the way back to g8 it just simpler
to play ya night h5 is something that
comes into consideration but
so nothing wrong was simply centralizing
like with Queen to d7 rook d8 maybe he
wants to wants to play Bishop III here
or
I don't know
he is yes three pawns for this piece but
they don't relay they don't really work
all that well together at the moment
yeah the night will come to d5 against
that is the that is the idea that his
God do this you should f6 Bishop takes
c3 I don't want a night coming 25 that
would be quite disturbing
okay he tries to do it now in a
different way okay
95 now however is is risky I mean 93
here it's very close it's very close to
working with with the meeting ideas on
the edge farm it's also 93 in this
position
it's going to go g3 yeah I'm so busy
looking finding a win that I'm probably
losing on time 24 seconds
well I hope it helped winning yeah
otherwise yeah I mean I think I think
I'm fine but it's a bit of an odd odd
position
it's good to have an increment but 14
seconds still not easy
mm what is the best he actually is this
I'm sure
eleven seconds
no I this is covered I'm such a [ __ ] my
god no I losing this game and would be
the worst yeah what a ridiculous thing
to do and now I'm belong to tread Queens
I'm losing this game don't believe this
[ __ ] sorry what a ridiculous game to
lose yeah you're like winning from fire
fear just take it forward just protected
twice yes that's a way to lose the game
it's great how ridiculous I mean you can
do a rook up yeah okay sorry for the
rent
hood I have to do it yeah these are the
kind of games that drive me nuts
really hey Lane yeah so yeah I know that
this is basically refuting the whole
opening here maybe defy this also what
the engine gives him the Cochran gambit
is just crap I mean anything else would
be too nice yeah okay well I mean I'm
better here as well
I was but no it doesn't matter what I'd
much thank you if you give away if we
look at the end yeah the piece is
clearly stronger here than three points
and I wouldn't really I wouldn't be
surprised if I hadn't made because I
mean you he's just going right into this
mate mechanism with 93 that actually
does not work but okay I was really down
and hope to to get the theta getting
settled the 94 was of course not bad I
mean that's the strategically good move
because before was giving me that square
for nothing but okay I was thinking that
should win
but in fact Quincy one is saving him
Quincy one night h4 Knight f4 is just
about holding okay yeah I mean after
that I'm just up up a ton of material
lc5 once been a night age three is still
continuing give him a fukken it's it
this is the story of the game
I'm giving giving full rooks is not
healthy I don't know I just had a
complete I was also thinking somebody
would take with the pawn but UK took
with the rook and I still took here it
was which was my intended move after
pawn takes and I don't know why I'm no
it's of course dead lost to the sea
pawns okay thanks a lot for watching